when you finish your third regular
season you can get that second contract
it hasn't happened yet we don't know
when it's gonna happen
mahomes keep saying things that suggest
he's going to do team friendly deals
most recently according to Yahoo Sports
obviously I want to get a contract
obviously I want to provide for my
family for a long time and do everything
like that but I want to make sure I do
it the smart way and do it the right way
so I don't know exactly which way that
is yet I know that my people and the
Chiefs people will talk about it we'll
do it at the right time and for the
betterment of the team I'm excited to be
a chief for a very long time I know
that's gonna be handle the right way
because of the people Chiefs having
their organization I mean look the
bottom line is there's two different
kinds of players and there is a spectrum
but at one end you've got the guy that
says it's your job to manage the salary
cap it's my job to make as much money as
I can at the other end is the guy who
will consciously take less trusting that
the team will put great players around
and it's each guys prerogative big-cat
but I'm a firm believer of getting paid
what you can while you can there's
enough money to go around and they'll
figure out how to put a team around him
the draft allows them to add cheap guys
whenever they want and they get to add
six or seven cheap guys every year I'm
not a big fan of saying of saying all
these things that suggest he's gonna do
a team friendly deal so what you said to
start that statement is the most
important part of this it's not that
Patrick mahomes is saying I'll take less
it's that he is implying that he trusts
the organization to use that extra money
wisely and I think that's the crucial
part here because I agree with you that
most of the time I am not in favor of
anyone taking less money than what they
deserve
but if Patrick Holmes trusts that the
Kansas City Chiefs will make his job a
lot easier there is a you know balance
that can be had here where he is says to
himself would I rather be in the Super
Bowl every year knowing that they will
make the right decisions and spend the
money the right way to make my job
easier to make you know to basically
bring the best pass from homes out or
will they you know take that money save
it put it down down field and be like
wow we'll just figure it out late
and basically get those like the the
alternator's patrick mahomes being so
good that he can carry your franchise to
the playoffs every year knowing that you
don't have to spend money in other
places that's really what it comes down
to best solution continues to be
something I've suggested in the past
it's something that Darrelle Revis tried
to get a decade ago the Jets didn't want
to do it Kirk Cousins has tried to get
it the Washington franchise and then the
Vikings didn't want to do it I think the
NFL doesn't want the teams to do it but
the right way to go if you're Patrick
mahomes you you have this conversation
one time and you're set for your career
you you enter into a business
partnership with the Chiefs and you
agree on what percentage of the salary
cap you will get period that's it every
it's 15 percent 18 percent sixteen point
three whatever it is that's what I get
that's what I mean to the team it's a
fair compromise and then the remaining
percentage is always available for the
rest of the team and you have faith that
they're going to put the team around if
that's what they need to do that's what
they should do and that prevents a
situation where a guy is getting
woefully underpaid and and also it just
puts it in the terms that you've put it
in it's a cooperation it's a partnership
and it's certainty for the Chiefs
although the numbers gonna change
they're gonna know what percentage of
the cap Patrick l'homme is is always
going to consume every year of his
career Mike you don't make a lot of good
points on this show oftentimes you some
trees just compliment me kid why does it
have to be conditional let me just say
the nice brilliance Mike oftentimes you
have nonsensical points that make no
sense that's a that's redundant there by
me but that doesn't matter you are
someone that people watch probably
because they hate more than they like
but in this case your point is great and
it's a great one and I totally agree
with you you have like it makes so much
sense to do what you're saying I almost
want you to be the next Commissioner of
the NFL let's get it going no thank you
no thank you no maybe 40 you know I
stopped yeah
it's probably more than that now yeah
most for most of the jobs I wouldn't do
it it's not worth it for that one for
the money involved now you look you got
you have to herd thirty-two cats all the
time and you you are the person who gets
blamed for everything they do or want to
do but for that much money there's a
lotta there's a lot of stuff that you
can that you can put up with I've put up
with a lot of stuff for far less money
now including you once a week see that's
the part when you're listing the pros
and cons commissioner the NFL you don't
have to put up with big cat once a week
that's in the pros that's near the top
that may be almost as high on the list
as the money okay
I'll throw this out there then your
Commissioner of the NFL you get paid a
hundred million dollars a year but on
Vice Commissioner of the NFL and we work
hand in hand every single day
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports